rond comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce mardi 17 novembre à manifestation
devant l'assemblée nationale en grande
partie des filets jaunes qui célèbre les
deux ans de leur mouvement et qui sont
venus rejoindre les opposants au projet
de loi sur la sécurité examiné par les
députés aujourd'hui un texte qui vise à
sanctionner la diffusion d'image de
policiers comme celles publiées souvent
pendant les manifestations de gilet
jaune alors qu'elle est aujourd'hui
l'héritage de ces gilet jaune ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
après le cessez le feu conclu au
karabagh le chef de la diplomatie
française appelle la russie à lever je
cite les ambiguïtés sur le rôle de la
turquie et sur les combattants étrangers
les sujets qui seront abordés lors d'une
réunion des coprésidents du groupe de
minsk demain à moscou précise jean yves
le drian et qui marquera également le
début de la négociation sur le statut du
haut karabagh
[Musique]
un colosse aux pieds d'argile ce
pourrait bien être le cas des membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu etats unis chine russie france et
royaume uni
hier leur rôle a été largement remis en
question et critiqué lors d'un débat
organisé durant l'assemblée générale de
l'organisme international a droit de
veto aux intérêts concurrents absence de
réponse comme une figure parmi les
arguments qui plaident en faveur d'une
réforme du conseil de sécurité
[Musique]
le mouvement des gilet jaune à dont deux
ans partis de montparnasse qu'ils ont
manifesté aujourd'hui pour retrouver un
autre rassemblement fort de l'assemblée
nationale où les députés examiner le
texte loi sur la sécurité globale
l'article 24 qui concerne la diffusion
de l'image de policiers en exercice est
toujours débat gérard darmanin vient de
confirmer la peine d'un an de prison et
45000 euros d'amendé pour la diffusion
de l'image d'un policier dans le but de
leur nuire et hier c'était le haut
commissariat aux droits de l'homme de
l'onu qui a fait part de ses inquiétudes
selon lui pourrait porter atteinte aux
droits de l'homme et à la liberté
d'informer une loi non se sentent
responsables en partie est léger sur
dheune écouter aujourd'hui pour
s'insurger et exprimer notre notre
comment dire notre aversion vis-à-vis de
cette nouvelle loi aujourd'hui qui va
être mis en place
et le plus triste aujourd'hui c'est que
quelque part les jets les jeunes sont
responsables de ça parce que on a su
mettre en avant aujourd'hui ce qui
n'allait pas en france on a su essayer
de tenter d'ouvrir les yeux aux français
je pense que le gouvernement si on
aperçoit que justement les français
ouvrent de plus en plus les yeux est la
meilleure façon de pouvoir qu à filtrer
tous leurs méfaits et
veut dire cacher l'ensemble des
violences policières il était
intéressant de pouvoir que de pouvoir
flouter les visages des policiers dont
convient aujourd'hui contre cette loi
aujourd'hui tu as 30 mutilés au sein des
gilets jaunes
tu n'as pas trente policiers en prison
et pourtant les vidéos sont là ça a été
vendu pour protéger les policiers
malheureusement ça ne protège pas les
policiers c'est moi protecteur que les
lois qui existent avant aujourd'hui
cirque là les policiers
s'il ya quelqu'un qui filme des
policiers ou les gendarmes et il faut
que subjectivement on puisse deviner
qu'il fait pour leur nuire s'il veut pas
leur nuire on va droit de les filmer
donc déjà ça va mettre le chaos sur la
voie publique ya déjà assez de
situations compliquées à gérer et la
personne qui veut vraiment aujourd'hui
nous nuire risque un an de prison et
45000 euros d'amendé
aujourd'hui le harcèlement par quelques
moyens que ce soit ces deux ans de
prison les menaces par quelques moyens
que ce soit sur les réseaux sociaux
entre autres ces trois ans de prison il
menace de voir ces cinq ans de prison
ces lois ne faut pas appliquer ce qu'il
ya des policiers qui sont effectivement
menacée sur les réseaux sociaux on veut
le réduire
ils sont harcelés voire menacé de mort
les gens qui font ça pour risques déjà
des peines jusqu'à cinq ans de prison
rien n'est fait donc ça veut dire que là
on nous propose une loi qui va être
madame irma avec une boule de cristal
très subjective et qui va être moins
protectrice pour les policiers mais quel
est le but est un article de loi qui ne
fait donc pas l'unanimité d'où cette
question liberté ou sécurité en france
faut-il désormais choisir c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
guillaume martin avocat de faouzi
lellouche et priscilla ludo ski bonsoir
guillaume martin merci d'être avec nous
à vos côté stanislas godon délégué
général alliance police bonsoir à vous
également ses mystères non merci d'être
avec nous manifestation de gilet jaune à
on l'a vu qu'ils sont toujours devant
l'assemblée nationale à l'heure où l'on
parle examen précisément pas les bonbons
du projet de loi de sécurité
le même jour sa fin gilet jaune qui
pourrait peut-être prendre cette
coïncidence comme un sacré pied de nez
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais c'est
ce dont mes côtés les manifestations
dans ce pays
c'est un droit constitutionnel donc il
n'est pas question de le contester après
mon nous déplorons déjà des jets de
projectiles sur mes collègues sur le
terrain qui n'était venu simplement veut
encadrer cette manifestation à proximité
de l'assemblée nationale
bon les gilet jaune se sont joints à
cette manifestation contre la loi
sécurité globale c'est leurs
revendications en tout cas nous on
continue à soutenir évidemment cette
proposition de loi
parce que il ya des éléments
intéressants pour notamment sécurisé
pour porter enfin un coup d'arrêt ce
police bashing qui se fait depuis des
mois des années
et puis également certaines dispositions
de la loi qui sont tout aussi protecteur
d'ailleurs pour les citoyens alors on a
vu un
cette loi certains j'ai les jambes
finalement s'en sentent responsables
puisque on rappelle que voilà beaucoup
de scènes ont été filmées par les
journalistes les manifestants pendant
précisément ces manifestations de gilet
jaune
le samedi selon vous où guillaume martin
est ce qu'il est pas normal finalement
en démocratie de pouvoir contrôler
demander des comptes à un agent public
je crois que c'est absolument
fondamental de pouvoir contrôler
l'exercice de l'ordre dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions les policiers qui agit
sur des terrains du maintien d'ordre des
manifestations
et puis on l'a vu ces dernières années
ça n'est pas une question théorique
c'est une question en réalité centrale
il ya un problème dans la gestion du
maintien de l'ordre à l'instar des
manifestations il ya des violences aussi
du côté d'un certain nombre de
manifestants c'est une chose l on peut
pas dire qu'ils ne soient pas qu'ils ne
fassent pas l'objet d'une attention
particulière la part des pouvoirs
publics
et je crois que les citoyens peuvent
doivent également pouvoir contrôler en
tout cas avoir pouvoir se fixer leur
propre opinion sur la façon dont les
choses se déroulent en manifestation du
côté des forces de police et je
comprends mal l'inquiétude des des
policiers à 7,7
ce besoin de de clarté sur la façon dont
les choses se déroulent en manifestation
guillaume martin qui prend on comprend
mal l'inquiétude des policiers qu est ce
qu elle voulait répondait alors d'avoir
répondent que effectivement la police
rendez compte
et d'ailleurs libre à chacun de saisir
les autorités compétentes parce que la
police est une des plus contrôlés au
monde des dispositions sont prises
puisque vous avez la plateforme igpn
faut les saisir le défenseur des droits
vous pouvez aussi filmer les policiers
en intervention
donc ya pas de débat de ce côté là
l'inquiétude elle est que les policiers
lorsque des vidéos sont faites et que
les visages sont diffusées lorsqu'ils
sont reconnues lent dans l'espace dans
la sphère familiale
eh bien ils sont
souvent attaqué nous avons des cas de
plus en plus récents deux policiers qui
sont reconnues qui sont agressés
notamment quand ils rentrent à leur
domicile
nous avons eu aussi des cas par le passé
tout aussi dramatique avec des concerts
de police qui ont été clairement
identifiés rappelez-vous de magnanville
rappelez-vous de honey rappelez vous
également de notre collègue à lyon il ya
quelques mois c'était au mois de juin
qui s'est fait agressé par plusieurs
individus qui a terminé sur un lit
d'hôpital
donc je crois que il faut arrêter
d'hystériser en fait le débat sur cet
article 24 de la loi il n'est pas
question d'interdire de films et
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas possible la loi
de 80 sur la liberté de la presse est
extrêmement clair sur le sujet nous ce
que l'on demande c'est juste qu'il y ait
une attention particulière pour que la
sécurité pour que l'intégrité physique
et psychique des policiers soient
préservés et je crois qu'il faut pas
oublier que derrière l'uniforme il ya
des hommes des femmes des pères de
famille et surtout des enfants qui
souvent subissent indirectement je
dirais l'exercice professionnel du
métier
et justement vous disais n'est pas
question de ne plus filmer
vous avez dans le sens de gérald
darmanin cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale qui tentent d'être rassurant
écouter le ministre de l'intérieur est
ce que les journalistes pourront
continuer à filmer la réponse est oui
pourront-ils continuer à diffuser la
réponse est oui
est ce qu'un citoyen pour un film et
l'intervention de police la réponse est
oui
pourra t-il dénoncé au procureur de la
république
la réponse est oui mais pourra-t-on
désormais faire des appels ou vient le
temps des policières pour un taux faire
des appels au meurtre sur des policiers
pour un taux demandé que leurs femmes
leurs enfants eux mêmes lorsqu'ils ont
supermarché lorsqu'ils rentrent chez eux
comme ces policiers magnanville côté
égorgé égorgé madame la députée devant
l'enfant de six ans parce qu'on les a
reconnu alors non et tant mieux car tic
24 soit adopté et guillaume martin est
votre réaction le ministre de
l'intérieur vous un petit peu convaincu
je ne mens pas je crois que le mini
l'intérieur kung fu qui y cite l'exemple
de magnanville alors qu'ils ont de
manobi ne correspond pas du tout à
l'objectif qui est fixé par cette loi
à quoi elle dit que toutes les images
qui serait diffusé avec une intention
malveillante l'image de policiers en
intervention serait réprimée par la loi
alors évidemment au plus 10 est pas
interdite diffusée il est pas interdite
films etc
la question c'est au delà de ce qui est
écrit dans la loi quelles seraient les
conséquences
la façon dont elle serait utilisée le
fait est que il ya aujourd'hui unanimité
et de la profession des journalistes
chez les avocats chez le défenseur des
droits les rapporteurs au conseil de
droits comme de l'onu etc etc qui tous
aujourd'hui disent qu'ils aient un effet
il y aura un effet pervers de cette a7 à
cette loi et on vous dit oui c'est pour
protéger les policiers d'abord je suis
un peu étonné parce que ce sujet des
policiers qui seraient traqués chez eux
après des images qui serait diffusée sur
internet est un sujet nouveau dont on
n'entendait jamais parlé avant première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que tout à
l'heure votre interlocuteur s'est trahi
lui-même avant même de parler deux
policiers qui seraient traqués qu'ils
seraient victimes de diffusion d'image
de leur image sur internet
il a parlé de la police bachir est le
problème il est là le problème c'est
qu'il ya une fraction aujourd'hui du
corps policier qu'il elle n'est pas que
l'on exposé à la vue de tous des
pratiques pour certaines d'entre elles
sont plus que discutables et même sans
doute illégal donc je crois que
aujourd'hui on vous posez la question
faut-il choisir entre la sécurité et la
liberté
je pense que ce sont des choses qui
s'oppose pas et puis il faut de voir de
quoi on parle en termes de sécurité je
ne suis pas certain que la sécurité des
policiers soient comment dire ne puisse
pas être garantie aujourd'hui le meut le
1er mai le ministre de l'intérieur dit
une chose qui est fausse lorsqu'il
laisse entendre qu aujourd'hui le la loi
ne permettrait pas de lutter contre ceux
qui appelleraient au viol qui a perdu
aux meurtres de policiers
et tout ça est prévue par le code pénal
tout ça est prévue par le code pénal
pourquoi ajouter une infraction donc on
sait en réalité que l'effet pervers ça
serait que les faits ne serait pas une
meilleure protection des policiers mais
dont on sait par contre que l'effet
pervers serait en réalité de limiter la
diffusion et même le fait de filmer des
comportements le discutable défense de
police au monde
de l'heure au moment des opérations de
maintenance je pense que ce texte est
très dangereux c'est pas pour rien qu'il
n'a ni mité contre contre lui et je
voudrais dire une chose c'est que c'est
un émoi à plusieurs textes ont été alors
pas forcément toujours sur les mêmes
sujets mais ont tous suivi la même
tendance qui tient à la réduction des
droits et des libertés
c ette dansant dans des contextes et sur
des sujets différents la walia elle
était sanctionnée par le conseil
constitutionnel parce que le loi parce
que l'euro parlementaire majoritaire à
l'assemblée nationale eh ben non pas
voulu entendre les avis et les critiques
étaient formulées contre cette loi c
était le cas où également sur la loi
contre les fins de peine des terroristes
les parlementaires gouvernement n'a pas
voulu entendre les critiques étaient
portées contre ce texte il a été
entièrement sur la parra conseil
constitutionnel je le dis aujourd'hui
j'espère que si ce texte devrait être
adopté
il sera porté à la connaissance et à
l'examen rigoureux de conseil
constitutionnel et je ne doute pas que
la conclusion à laquelle il ya un vrai
qu'on s'est constitué à c'est une
nouvelle fois de dire en réalité ce
texte n'est pas conforme à nos principes
essentiels à nos principes
constitutionnels lui le gouvernement et
le groupe majoritaire devrait entendre
cela la naissance de donges en revient à
la question initiale effectivement
liberté ou sécurité faut-il désormais
choisir ça pourrait être un sujet de
philosophie du bac vous comprenez tout
de même cette inquiétude ne vont pas vos
détracteurs à vous mais les détracteurs
de cette loi c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup d'affaires on les cite souvent
en exemple la faire se souvient même
finalement la sphère georgetown aux
états unis qui n'auraient pas été
révélée sans ce type de vidéos est ce
que ça vous le conseiller tout de même
absolument pas puisque d'ailleurs c'est
c'est bien vous me demandiez la perche
plus que dans l'article 24 de la loi il
est très clairement spécifié que si vous
êtes détenteur de vidéos qui permettent
de faire la lumière sur ce que vous
supposez être une action de police qui
serait pas dans la cadre réglementaire
nom d anthologie co qui tomberait sous
le coup au pénal vous avez tout le
loisir
transmettre ces vidéos à l'autorité
judiciaire et l'autorité administrative
donc je ne vois pas où est le problème
dans à la fois le fait de filmer de
recueillir des vidéos et de les diffuser
à l'autorité judiciaire et enfin mettre
vous vous êtes trompés parce que vous
avez parlé de diffuser les interventions
de police mais ça vous pouvez diffuser
les intentions plessis a pas de débat
l'article de loi ne disent pas ça
l'article il dit diffusé le visage des
policiers ou tout élément permettant de
les identifier
c'est en ça que le police bashing et
l'or et que les policiers sont souvent
traquer jusqu'à leur domicile
c'est en ça aussi que les policiers sont
obligés de déménager quand parfois ils
subissent une controverse des
accusations parce que vous avez m
souvent les condamnations se font sur
les réseaux sociaux et non pas dans les
prétoires et c'est bien regrettable
parce que vous qui êtes attachés au
droit vous savez très bien que il faut
l'argument de la défense
il faut aussi l'argument du ministère
public et il faut aussi au milieu quand
même et garantir un peu je dirais la
sécurité physique et mentale de ces
policiers qui je le rappelle prennent
des risques je le rappelle sont vingt
blessés par jour à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
et je crois que l'heure est assez grave
pour qu'on ne mette pas de l'huile sur
le feu je crois que cette loi ne va pas
aussi loin que vous le dites
elle n'est pas liberticide elle ne porte
pas atteinte à la loi de la presse à la
loi de 80 et tout le monde aura le
loisir
encore une fois je le dis de filmer des
policiers en intervention
le modem à séoul où il est possible de
porter des recours etc et que c'est en
définitive à l'autorité judiciaire de
trancher le fait le fait est que
l'ensemble des procédures sur les
centaines de plaintes ont été saisi
l'igpn
la plupart ont abouti à aucune procédure
pourtant on sait et les images et on le
sait parce que les images son public
elle ne le serait sans doute pas avec
l'adoption de cette loi on sait qu'il ya
un sujet de violences policières et qui
ne sont pas toujours qui n'aboutissent
pas toujours à des poursuites et il ya
un vrai sujet s'agissant de ces dix ans
du fonctionnement de l'igpn
par ailleurs une dernière chose cette
loi est dit c'est la diffusion avec
l'intention de nuire
kelly qui la définissent
de cette intention de nuire on parle
encore une fois de sécurité je crois
qu'il faut aussi parler de sécurité
juridique
est ce que les français avec ce texte
seront lorsqu'ils diffusent une image si
la diffuse avec une intention de nuire
ou pas qu'est ce qu'une intention de
nuire
c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas d'accord
avec la parution a été mon entrain
d'assister
je pense que c'est extrêmement grave
c'est un vrai sujet et je crois que et
ces deux là dessus que j'alerte y
compris le hall low vernon et je suis
pas le seul nombreux sans le faire j'ai
vu que le conseil de l'ordre du barreau
de paris vient de prendre une motion
aujourd'hui qui va dans ce sens et il y
attention ce texte ce texte est pris
dans la précipitation
surtout ce texte si les prix pour
satisfaire une fraction du corps
policier mais il ne répond pas aux
exigences constitutionnelles qui
régissent encore aujourd'hui un autre
droit
merci à tous les deux guillaume martin
stanislas godon d'avoir été avec nous
pour débattre de cette loi qui est
examiné à partir d'aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale merci à vous et on
le disait une journée qui fait date les
deux ans du mouvement des gilets jaunes
dont ils ont convergé vers l'assemblée
nationale où se tient bien de dire
l'examen du projet de loi sur la
sécurité globale les précisions avec
notre reporter sur place pierre qui
savent hivernaux
et pierre bonsoir
qu'est ce qui se passe quelle est
l'atmosphère sur place on a vu des
images un petit peu agitée
la situation semble revenir au calme
alors on nous parle en a pas vraiment
stéphanie avec lucas turquie derrière la
caméra on sort justement d'un nuage de
gaz lacrymogène vous voyez autour de moi
c'est légèrement la confusion une
manifestation qui s'était bien passé
jusqu'ici entre gilet jaune et et
contestataire justement de cette loi
sécurité globale et puis c'est il ya une
heure environ que les choses ont un peu
changé par vous excusez moi c'est le
sait le gaz lacrymogènes je pense je
pense qu'on reviendra justement vers
vous dans quelques minutes un pur pour
vous expliquer tout ça parce que la
situation là est un peu un peu compliqué
pour nous effectivement il ya deux
minutes s'étaient calmées
les autorités sont passées à la
dispersion effectivement avec ces gaz
lacrymogènes pierre pissavy yvernault
vous retrouvera peut-être plus tard les
deux ans des gilet jaune quel est le
bilan social de ce mouvement notamment
en quoi ça tout de suite avec l ex époux
lancer notre rubrique l'édito est pas de
jingle c'est pas grave
bonsoir alexis poulain mercier et voilà
vous êtes un jingle à vous tout seul
merci d'être avec nous 17 novembre 2010
8 17 novembre 2020 donc deux ans que
gilet jaune et pourquoi
finalement quel est le bilan aujourd'hui
alors c'est un bilan extrêmement amer
finalement de cette incroyable épopée
sociale qui a révélé les extrêmes
inégalités les risques qui était ce que
faisait courir cette politique d'
emmanuel macron mais aussi la marche du
monde à la société française et gilet
jaune ils ont été il y a deux ans les
canaris de la mine ceux qui ont alerté
sur ce risque grandissant de la
paupérisation de la précarisation d'une
partie importante de la classe moyenne
qui est pourtant un des socles de notre
société et de la république française
c'était un cri de protestation d'abord
sur l'augmentation d'une taxe taxe
carbone qui faisait que le carburant
s'envolait et ont touché la au
porte-monnaie des gens qui avaient
besoin de la voiture pour aller
travailler et qui est bien avec du mal à
finir la fin de mois alors qu'ils
étaient intégrés qu'il travaillait et
qu'il pensait être les gagnants de cette
mondialisation qu'on avait vendu comme
étant heureuse
or ils se sont avérés être les perdants
et lycées de contestation est très vite
tombé dans la colère face au refus de
vouloir entendre
rappelez vous les premiers commentaires
moqueurs qui avait été fait c'est gilet
jaune fumeurs de klopp qui rouler au
diesel et cetera la mort d'edouard
philippe et du gouvernement face à cette
contestation sociale qu'il ne comprenait
pas tout simplement puisque c'était
normal de payer une taxe carbone ça
allait dans le bon sens pour l'écologie
et il ya eu là la prise des ronds-points
sert au point ces zones
périurbaines où il vivait nombre de
gilet jaune où ils ont commencé à se
rassembler à découvrir la solidarité à
voir que finalement le nombre comptait
que ce gilet jaune ce symbole des
déclassés de ceux qui font le travail
quotidien invisible les les invisibles
se rendaient visible avec ce gilet jaune
et c'était assez formidable dans les
premiers mois il faut savoir que entre
le 17 novembre et le 21 décembre
quand même une dizaine de morts sur ces
barrages routiers gilet jaune et et
autres confondues et puis ensuite il ya
eu la rue les manifestations tous les
samedis les actes
petit à petit la lutte qui était celle
du pouvoir d'achat est devenu finalement
un mouvement citoyen qui demandait une
autre démocratie face à la confiscation
du pouvoir qui a été fait par les élites
auto proclamées et alexis poulain une
répression évidemment sont bien d'une
violente ce qu'on peut qualifier
d'inédite oui c'est la seule réponse qui
a été apportée finalement sous couvert
bien sûr de protéger les commerces les
bons citoyens de la violence de ces
gilet jaune vu comme violent il faut se
rappeler que les premières
manifestations étaient unitaire et que
les gilets jaunes applaudissait la
police les remercier et leur demandait
d'ailleurs de se joindre à eux
puisqu'ils étaient d'une certaine façon
eux aussi porter de gilet jaune et
quelle a été la réponse du pouvoir très
rapidement très rapidement
ça a été une répression sanglante d'une
violence inouïe
les comptes font peur ils ne sont pas
encore terminées puisqu'on est à deux
ans mais david e
dufresne le journaliste avait fait un
décompte avec son compte à l'eau place
beauvau c'est plus de 4400 aux blessés
et 24 qui ont été les borniers qui ont
perdu un oeil certains étaient des
figures du mouvement comme jérôme
rodriguez et cinq qui ont eu la main
arrachée côté du des forces de l'ordre
place beauvau faisait état de 1944
blessés et on a vu finalement la
violence la répression d'état se mettre
en place d'une manière inédite jusqu'à
présent simplement pour faire taire
cette répression qu'on ne voulait pas
entendre
et quand c'était impossible de continuer
parce qu'il aurait fallu tuer des gens
la violence montant chaque fois d'un
cran
le lanceur de balles de défense est une
arme de guerre il faut voir la façon
dont la répression a été organisée par
par la nouvelle doctrine mise en place
par christophe castaner alors miser
l'intérieur est aussi edouard philippe
le premier ministre il a fallu quand
même à arrêter ou temporiser
emmanuel macron a sorti de sa poche la
carte du grand débat l'idée c'était de
faire croire que les revendications à
celle des citoyens le leur à le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne la
volonté de parler les cahiers de
doléances qui avait été écrit au beau
père ont des mairies tout cela était
mise en scène dans la parole et la geste
présidentiel qui a monopolisé le débat
tout simplement en se mettant en scène
dans le cadre de la campagne des
européennes
ce grand débat qui a coûté plusieurs
millions d'euros aux contribuables a
permis à manuel macro finalement de
faire croire que le dialogue était
enclenché avec les gilet jaune or les
salle était remplie d'un public trié sur
le volet et gille et joli t il c'est
bien bien à l'écart et finalement de
dialogue il n'y eut pas à lui que ce
faux grand débat alors que les gilets
jaunes avaient organisé un vrai débat
qu'ils avaient écrit leurs
revendications qui étaient déjà recensés
sur les cahiers de doléances donc voilà
la vraie arnaque d'une certaine façon ou
le coup de poker des modèles macron qui
a refusé finalement de parler au gilet
jaune et qui s'est mis lui en scène
faisant semblant de parler au peuple
français et la question évidemment lexie
est-ce que les gilet jaune ont disparu
non certainement pas alors certes ils
ont été rendues invisibles par les lois
de répression d'interdiction quasiment
ni festation il y avait ces images alors
on n'a plus droit maintenant de filmer
les forces de l'anp si jamais la loi de
sécurité globale passait mais où un crs
essayé d'exploser avec sa botte un
ballon de baudruche jaune tout ce qui
avait la couleur jaune finalement
devenait séditieux comme disait
christophe castaner à l'époque donc on a
très vite compris les manifestants qu'il
fallait enlever les gilet jaune mais
aimer ça ne veut pas dire que les
revendications premières des gilets
jaunes les craintes première des gilets
jaunes ou mes colères qui était celle de
ne pas être entendu de ne pas être
écoutés de devoir des politiques
publiques qui les oubliait
systématiquement ceux là sont toujours
là bien présent et je pense que les
rangs n'ont fait que gonfler
même si la rue s'est vidée par crainte
simplement d'une blessure parce que tout
le monde a vu la violence dont était
capable ce gouvernement est bien la
contestation elle est toujours présente
et elle est même les sondeurs en sont
très conscients jusqu'à un dernier
sondage qui était sorti de fondapol en
octobre faisait état de 79 % des
électeurs qui envisage un vote anti
système en 2022 c'est à dire un barrage
finalement anti macron de voter tout
sauf les partis en place et
particulièrement la république en marche
ça voudrait dire huit électeurs sur dix
qui qui préférait le vote blanc
l'abstention ou un vote anti système en
2022 donc c'est à dire comment
finalement c'est de cette colère et
cette défiance vis-à-vis des pouvoirs
publics n'a fait qu'augmenter et puis
arrive par dessus la crise du
coronavirus crises sanitaires
extrêmement mal gérée depuis le mois de
mars et on voit aujourd'hui les
commerçants qui n'étaient pas gilet
jaune puisque je devais fermer boutique
tous les samedis et qui se retrouvaient
sur le pavé à les regarder passer c'est
à dire et si j'ai moi même j'étais
finalement un gilet jaune si j'étais le
prochain sur la liste le prochain des
perdants de cette politique et la
crainte je pense aujourd'hui du
gouvernement qui va faire beaucoup de
chèques et essayer de subventionner
autant que faire se peut des secteurs
qu'ils ferment les uns après les autres
c'est d'éviter que les commerçants se
joignent aux rouges et jaunes et que
grandisse ce mouvement qui n'a pas
trouvé finalement d'aboutissement
politique mais tout ça n'est pas fini
malgré l'entrisme des partis politiques
je crois que il ya une intelligence
politique de ce mouvement citoyen
gilet jaune qui a refusé de la
récupération et qui a décidé de s'auto
organiser et aujourd'hui université
citoyenne grand rendez-vous les gilet
jaune continue d'être actif
politiquement de se politiser et de
chercher finalement une sortie une issue
pour rendre finalement la démocratie est
le pouvoir au peuple pour qu'il soit
gouvernée par le peuple et pour le
peuple
ce qui est loin d'être le cas
aujourd'hui merci alexis poulain
justement c'est gilet jaune qui
célèbreront le disait alors deux ans
aujourd'hui qui ont convergé vers
l'assemblée nationale où se tient
précisément l'examen du projet de loi
sur la sécurité globale dont ils se
sentent un petit peu responsable on va
retrouver à nouveau notre reporter
pierre pissavy yvernault qui a été gazés
tout à l'heure lors d'une dispersion de
cette manifestation pierre on espère que
vous allez mieux est ce que l'atmosphère
c'est un petit peu apaisées qu'est ce
qui s'est passé tout à l'heure à compter
nous
eh bien écoutez stéphanie nous étions
comme tous les manifestations comme tous
les manifestants à pardon sur cette
petite place juste à côté de l'assemblée
nationale et puis à vers 19h30 la police
à a demandé la dispersion de cette place
et c'est vers le boulevard saint germain
où nous sommes actuellement que tous les
manifestants se sont réunis la police
bloque actuellement les deux côtés on ne
peut pas à sortir vers ce côté ci qui
donne du côté de la scène hiver l'autre
côté qui donne vers le sud de paris ce
qui fait que tous les gens autour de
nous vous voyez sur les images de duca
tu as sont vraiment assez entre ces deux
cordons de police
alors ce qui nous arrive est tout à
l'heure c'est très simple la police a
fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes
effectivement une dispersion qui est un
peu lente se voit là pour pour tous ces
gens qui sont ici
beaucoup de personnes sont partis
beaucoup qui était tout à l'heure à la
manifestation ont quitté les lieux il
reste maintenant voilà peut-être un
petit peu plus d'un an milliers de
personnes beaucoup de jeunes pour la
plupart - de gilet jaune mais je les
journaux on n'en voit plus beaucoup
à l'heure actuelle voilà en tout cas ce
qu'on peut vous dire c'est vraiment que
la dispersion est assez compliquée la
police bouge vraiment toutes les
zissu ici du côté du du boulevard saint
germain et semble pousser vraiment les
manifestants vers le métro justement
pour tenter de les faire partir ce qui
n'est pas forcément la première option
des manifestantes pour l'instant merci
pierre fils habib hivernaux les études
n'hésitez pas sur toi nous rappeler
voilà si les évènements devaient évoluer
sur place donc devant l'assemblée
nationale où une manifestation donc
tombe de se faire dispersés par les
forces de l'ordre avec son but il de la
difficulté comme vous nous l'avez
expliqué merci à vous les directions à
présent les territoires du haut karabagh
ou le cessez le feu entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan sous la surveillance de la
russie commence à porter ses fruits
les réfugiés peuvent désormais rentrer à
stepanakert par le couloir de latchine
sécurisée par les forces russes le
maintien de la paix notre envoyé spécial
kirill petit coffre qui est sur place
nous racontent leur parcours entre
douleur et soulagement
la route est étroite sinueuse
parfois dangereuses
mais elle est rouverte
le couloir de latchine peut désormais
être utilisée par ceux qui veulent se
rendre dans le haut-karabagh
deuxième point d'arrêt la ville de
chouchi à une dizaine de kilomètres de
stepanakert c'est ici que se trouve la
zone neutre et c'est ici que tout le
monde se croise la présence des forces
russes du maintien de la paix est la
pierre angulaire du bon fonctionnement
du cessez-le-feu poste numéro 2 à
proximité du village de shoushi situé à
une dizaine de kilomètres de stepanakert
c'est ici que tout se passe c'est ici
que la police aux frontières
azerbaïdjanaise travail avec les forces
de maintien de la paix russes qui se
trouve juste à côté à quelques mètres de
là la frontière azerbaïdjanaise nous ne
pouvons pas les films et kara no man's
land 2 5 km doivent être respectées
entre les deux parties c'est ici aussi
que les colonnes de réfugiés arrivent en
direction de stepanakert par bus pour
arriver jusqu à stepanakert il faut
passer plusieurs contrôles et parfois
affronter les stigmates du conflit la
ville est désormais azéri
beaucoup d'éléments le rappelle mais au
moins la paix est revenue sur ce poste
de contrôle
le drapeau de l'azerbaïdjan côtoie celui
de la russie lorsqu'ils sont arrivés ici
les forces russes du maintien de la paix
ont trouvé un terrain totalement
dévastée vous le voyez ici c'est le
monument d'entrée de la ville de chouchi
il est à terre c'est très symbolique
vous voyez c'est très fort et derrière
il y a encore des carcasses de voitures
avec des impacts de balles
en tout cas le commandant de ce poste de
contrôle nous explique que désormais la
paix ici est revenu malgré des mines qui
sont placés tout autour ce couloir est
désormais ouvert pour laisser passer les
réfugiés les réfugiés qui arrivent par
colonne de bus pour rejoindre
stepanakert enfin pour eux ce trajet est
terminée les forces de maintien de la
paix assure la sécurité de tous ceux qui
rentrent dans les territoires du haut
karabagh chaque voiture est fouillé s'il
ya des armes
je voulais qu'on puisqu'on évidemment et
si tout est propre
nous les laissons passer et ces
personnes peuvent librement circuler le
long du corridor de latchine entier et
thierry dol et watkins coco les dom les
réfugiés qui sont acheminés en bus
depuis la ville de gori sa 300
kilomètres de là sont exportés jusqu'à
la place principale de stepanakert c'est
là qu'ils pourront enfin souffler et
regagner leurs foyers qu'ils ont dû fuir
pendant plusieurs mois
ce monument juste derrière moi est le
symbole de la ville de stepanakert qui
se trouve juste à l'entrée de la ville
et c'est par cette route que sont en
train d'arriver les colonnes de bus de
réfugiés qui sont escortés par la police
arménienne et par les forces russes du
maintien de la paix jusqu'à la place
principale de la ville à quelques
kilomètres de là après plusieurs
semaines voire parfois plusieurs mois
d'exil les réfugiés peuvent enfin
retrouver leur maison à stepanakert pour
certains il va falloir tout recommencer
à zéro et entre doute pour l'avenir et
le bonheur la frontière est parfois
mince
nous sommes enfin rentrer chez nous on
ne sait encore ce qu'on va faire
qui vivra verra évidemment nous avons
peur après tout ce que nous avons vu
honnêtement je ne pense pas que tout le
monde rentrera la nouvelle génération
les jeunes vous régler leurs problèmes à
leur façon différemment de nous il y a
des années nous l'ancienne génération
avons toujours vécu avec l'idée d'une
grande armée soviétique braves est forte
si dieu le veut les choses s'arrangeront
mais qui sait combien de temps cela va
prendre
nous sommes arrivés sans problème tout
s'est bien passé on est parti à 8 heures
du matin et nous voilà arrivés
honnêtement je ne sais pas comment je
vois l'avenir j'espère que les forces
russes de maintien de la paix nous
aideront à nous remettre sur pied
bien sûr que je suis contente s'il
n'avait pas été là nous n'aurions jamais
pu revenir chez nous comment faire sans
eux il n'y a que grâce à eux que nous
pouvons nous sentir en sécurité
je pense que tout le monde va rentrer
oui quelques heures d'électricité par
jour des magasins qui commencent à
rouvrir la vie reprend à stepanakert et
le président russe s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui à ce sujet vladimir poutine
affirmant que le statut définitif du
haut karabagh n'a pas encore été
déterminé que moscou maintient le statu
quo il ajoute avoir grandement apprécié
l'implication de la france et des états
unis dans le règlement de la situation
dans le haut karabagh et pour en parler
nous sommes avec pierre emmanuel thomas
professeur de géopolitique fondateur
d'euro continent bonsoir pierre-emmanuel
toman merci d'être avec nous on vient de
dire la lumière poutine qui affirme que
le statut 1 du haut karabagh n'a pas
encore été déterminé que moscou
maintenait le statu quo une réunion a eu
lieu à lieu demain sur ce sujet quoi
faut-il s'attendre selon vous alors je
pense que une fois ce cessez le feu
obtenu sous l'égide de la russie c'était
la seule puissance qui pouvait avoir une
influence décisive pour arrêter les
combats
l'avenir du haut karabakh évidemment
n'est pas encore réglé nous revenons à
la situation d'un conflit gelé je dirais
puisque les arméniens aimerait
évidemment conserver ce qui reste du
haut karabakh mais les azéri considère
que tout le karabakh d'oeuvre est sous
administration azérie
et donc il y as rivalité des visions sur
sur ce territoire est en quelque sorte
pour stabiliser la situation à long
terme évidemment ce qui est décisif
c'est le la force de paix d'imposition
de la russie sans qui les arméniens
n'aurait pas de sécurité mais pour
régler définitivement la question du
haut-karabakh sans doute que les dj les
grandes puissances vont à nouveau se
réunir et essayer de discuter mais comme
elles ont des intérêts divergents il
sera très difficile d'arriver à un
accord global et donc je pense que la
solution la plus probable est le retour
à une situation gelé alors jean yves le
drian demandé à moscou de lever
l'ambiguïté sur le cessez le feu le rôle
de la turquie et sur les combattants
étrangers
sincèrement on se pose la question le
groupe de minsk est il toujours légitime
pour régler la situation sur place est
demandée ainsi des comptes
alors effectivement là il ya la rivalité
russo turque qui est derrière ce conflit
aussi même si la russie et la turquie
arrive toujours à de manière pragmatique
à négocier pour ne pas arriver à une
collision frontale et la turquie avait
demandé évidemment des participer à
cette force d'interposition ce qui a été
refusé par la russie parce qu'évidemment
le haut karabakh le caucase du sud en
général c'est l'étrange l'étranger
proche de la russie et la turquie est
membre autant il ne faut pas l'oublier
donc la russie ne pouvait pas donner un
statut égal à la turquie et a repris la
main je dirais à l'occasion de ce
conflit
mais les le groupe de minsk a été
écartée des négociations pour établir un
cessez-le-feu et c'est assez logique si
l'on analyse l'évolution de la
configuration géopolitique mondiale en
fait où les institutions le groupe de
minsk l'eau scee l'otan l'union
européenne afin d'aider toutes les
nations unies qui avait pignon sur rue
cependant je dirais la guerre froide et
ensuite la période unipolaire où
c'étaient les états unis et les
occidentaux qui dominent et lassana
tartas internationale ces organisations
pouvaient gérer le multilatéralisme les
négociations entre les états mais
aujourd'hui elle ne reflète plus la
réalité du terrain la réalité
géopolitique avec le retour de la russie
dans le dans son étranger proche
la montée en puissance de la turquie est
donc ce n'est plus le lieu principal des
négociations décisives mais évidemment
la france et des états unis vont essayer
de revenir dans le jeu pour participer
aux négociations et invoqué de demander
des réunions du groupe de minsk
mais ce ne sera pas je pense pas que ce
restera le coeur du dispositif pour
régler la question du haut karabakh
il faut voir aussi que
la russie a réussi à endiguer la turquie
qui voulait un rôle beaucoup plus
important et la turquie membres temps et
on s'est étonné en fait du du retrait
des états unis des occidentaux durant
cette crise mon interprétation et qu'
ils ont fermé les yeux parce que la
turquie
ça arrange les états unis d'endiguer la
turquie lorsqu'elles menacent de diviser
les membres autant parle par exemple en
méditerranée orientale mais retourner la
turquie contre la russie sert les
intérêts atlantiste et donc la russie
s'est extrêmement bien rétabli parce
qu'il faut pas oublier de le contexte
général où ou la russie subit la
pression en biélorussie le cren soutenu
par les états unis la géorgie aussi qui
essaie de se rapprocher de l'otan et de
l'union européenne et la sphère navalni
et cette crise dans le haut karabakh est
venu se surajouter à cet arc de crise et
aussi en syrie où les états unis en fait
soutiennent la turquie a accueilli pour
empêcher la russie est là et la syrie
loyal de bachar el assad d'avoir une
victoire totale en syrie dont vous le
jeu est extrêmement complexe
nadim routine qui dit avoir grandement
apprécié l'implication de la france et
des états unis dans le règlement de la
situation dans le haut karabagh c'est
plutôt fair-play poteau diplomate
mais ce qu'on peut dire quand même
clairement que sur ce dossier la russie
était quasiment seuls à la manoeuvre
évidemment c'est la russie qui avait
toutes les cartes en main et en réalité
au delà de déclarations d'amitié de la
part de la france pour l'arménie une
tentative de cessez-le-feu humanitaire
de la part des états unis
la france aussi a participé à demander à
ce qu'un cessez-le-feu mais ils n'y sont
pas arrivés parce qu'ils n'ont pas là
toutes les cartes en main et en réalité
ils n'ont pas été capables de faire
pression sur la turquie qui est derrière
l'azerbaïdjan donc il n'y avait que la
russie qui a
évidement à des intérêts régionaux de
sécurité c'est le l'étranger proche de
la russie et qui a pu faire pression sur
la turquie pour imposer un cessez-le-feu
et comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
mon interprétation et qu'en fait la
plupart des pays de l'otan ne voulait
pas faire pression pour la turquie parce
que retourner la turquie contre la
russie arrange les intérêts atlantiste
et des tours de la turquie je dirais des
intérêts des pays membres de l'otan en
méditerranée orientale
donc c'est toute la rue la russie avait
toutes les cartes en main et était seule
en fait pour imposer ce cessez le feu et
l'a réussi merci pierre emmanuel
tordjman professeur de géopolitique
fondateur d'euro continent cette
question quel rôle pour le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu dans la crise
sanitaire mondiale l'institution semble
en retrait depuis le début de la
pandémie lui a fallu plus de trois mois
pour adopter le 1er juillet une
résolution appelant à davantage de
coopération internationale
en cause les divergences entre les
etats-unis et la chine notamment face
aux dissensions entre les grandes
puissances le conseil de sécurité
internationales semblent impuissantes
françois xavier lambert ce sont des
critiques récurrentes depuis la création
de l'onu en 1945 75 ans après l'utilité
de l'organisation des nations unies et
de ses agences est régulièrement remise
en cause par plusieurs pays et parfois
même par ses propres employés
le président de l'assemblée générale de
l'onu a ainsi dénoncé lundi dernier
l'inefficacité du conseil de sécurité
l'organe qui peut décider de l'emploi de
la force partout dans le monde à de
nombreuses reprises le conseil a failli
à sa responsabilité de maintenir la paix
et la sécurité internationales les
intérêts concurrents de ses membres et
le recours fréquent au droit de veto ont
limité l'efficacité du conseil de
sécurité
ces critiques visent une institution qui
n'a pas été réformé depuis plusieurs
décennies
le président français a lui aussi
souligné le manque de solutions
apportées par l'organisation en raison
des divergences entre les pays qui la
composent
je suis obligé de constater que le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies ne
produit plus de solutions utiles
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous
co-responsables quand certains
deviennent les otages des crises du
multilatéralisme comme l' oms par
exemple parmi les principaux griefs
adressés à l'onu son incapacité à peser
dans les conflits actuels de la syrie au
yémen en passant par les tensions au
proche orient et à la menace du
terrorisme international
une faiblesse qui affecte également les
piliers de son action sur le terrain les
casques bleus
ces militaires censés maintenir la paix
sont régulièrement accusés de commettre
de graves abus
ils ont notamment été au coeur de
scandales sexuels en centrafrique au
mali ou encore en république
démocratique du congo
mais le plus grands échecs récents de
l'onu réside surtout dans son
impuissance face à la guerre en syrie en
raison de tensions entre les cinq
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité la russie et la chine ont
opposé leur veto à toute intervention
sous mandat de l'onu
pékin et moscou n'ont jamais oublier
l'intervention des occidentaux en libye
qui n'avait pas respecté le cadre
initial de la résolution votée en 2011
une intervention qui s'étaient soldées
par des opérations au sol et la mort du
colonel kadhafi cette incapacité du
conseil de sécurité à dégager des
consensus est également dénoncée par
moscou
le président français est parfaitement
conscient que le conseil de sécurité
n'est pas une autorité indépendante qui
prend les décisions de son plein gré
mais une structure collégiale avec
notamment une participation française
l'efficacité de ces décisions dépend
directement de la capacité des cinq
membres permanents à s'entendre
c'est dans ce contexte que l'onu tente
d'amorcer une difficile réforme ses 193
membres ont ainsi évoqué lundi les
conditions de recours au droit de veto
le privilège des cinq membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité au coeur des
discussions également l'élargissement de
la composition de l'instance
outre ces cinq membres permanents
l'organe est composé de dix membres non
permanents désigné pour un mandat de
deux ans l'allemagne le brésil le japon
l'inde ainsi que plusieurs pays
africains ont réaffirmé leur souhait
d'obtenir un siège permanent au conseil
de sécurité
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
dominique
cinq anciens chefs de la mission
militaire française à l'onu bonsoir
général merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france on a vu un emmanuel macron
très critique envers cette institution
caché rechute il selon vous oui bonsoir
et bien écoutez les problèmes avec le
conseil de sécurité sont pas nouveau ça
fait plusieurs années j'allais dire
dizaine d'années qu'on en parle
simplement dans les propos du président
français
il y a deux objets le premier le blocage
récent les braquages récents qui sont
dus essentiellement à l'utilisation du
veto de façon quasiment systématique en
particulier dans le cas de la crise en
syrie est le deuxième sujet c'est bien
sûr la place de l'europe qu'il souligne
parce que ça n'a pas un lien direct avec
le conseil de sécurité mais c'est un
contrepoids qu'il voit s'installer entre
le combat je voulais dire entre les deux
grands que sont les états unis et la
chine
alors comment expliquer la passivité du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu justement
sur la crise nous convient de 19 puisque
c'est de là que sont partis en tout cas
ses récentes critiques même si celle
d'at depuis longtemps comme vous le
soulignez et bien écoutez je crois que
conseil de sécurité pour être plus
global à trois problèmes un problème de
représentativité un problème de
gouvernance et un problème d' usage du
veto qui fait partie de la gouvernance
et pour la question que vous me posez
c'est sur ces derniers points que nous
allons élaborer c'est à dire que kovy de
il ya eu des velléités d'en traiter mais
en fait aucun des membres permanents n'a
voulu vraiment traité et donc
naturellement ça ne n'était pas sur la
table
je rappelle que la france a été à
l'origine d'une demande d'une réunion du
p5 les permanentes farrell
les cinq membres permanents pour essayer
de débloquer le système et les autres
membres permanents n'ont pas souhaité
répondre à cette demande française qui
évidemment amène à une absence de
discussion complet
sur cette partie qui est la partie de
gouvernance et usages du voeu du droit
de veto vers le droit de veto la france
avait fait des propositions en
particulier en disant qu'il ne pouvait
pas être utilisée dans le cas où il y
aurait un danger pour l'humanité à une
utilisation tout à fait disproportionné
de la force et personne n'a retenu ces
propositions finalement j'en ai 25 ans
qu aurait pu faire l'onu en l'espèce
dans cette crise sanitaire est ce que
l'institution avait une marge de
manoeuvre significative pour tenter
d'améliorer la situation était
différente aussi en fonction des pays
évidemment oui alors il faut élargir là
aussi le cercle de l'onu s'est pas
seulement le conseil de sécurité ni
l'assemblée générale et dans le cas du
coc u19 c'est bien sûr l'om s et comme
vous le savez les etats-unis ont décidé
de se retirer de l'eau oms qui est pas
une façon très futés j'allais dire de
travailler avec un organisme
international en étant à l'extérieur où
on a plus d' influence sur ce cet
organisme et il aurait fallu bien sûr
que l' oms et le poids des etats-unis
comme d autres pays pour pouvoir avoir
un objet de gouvernance dans cette dans
cette crise qu aurait pu faire d'autres
l'om est ce parce qu'on sait qu'elle a
été extrêmement critique et dans la
gestion de la crise vous l'avez dit les
etats unis qui ont claqué la porte
critiquant notamment l' oms d'être à la
botte des chinois est ce que l'image va
être abîmée à la sortie de cette crise
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
alors le premier point c'est qu'il faut
souligner que monsieur joe biden le
président élu qui va être annoncé
j'espère très bientôt a décidé de
rejoindre le ms ce qui me paraît une
mesure très sage l'om est évidemment été
critiqué parce qu'elle a mis un peu de
temps avant de dire que c'était une
pandémie et
le directeur général de l'om est ce qui
est un éthiopien a été accusé par les
états unis d'être à la botte des chinois
qui avait retardé aussi bien sur la
déclaration de pandémie
donc il est probable que il elle aurait
dû réagir plus vite et simplement il
faut peut-être réforme est incertain de
choses à l'intérieur et mesk mais c'est
en étant à l'intérieur qu'on peut le
souligner au début de notre discussion
nous parlions des difficultés de l'onu
je voudrais simplement appelée rappeler
une intervention du président macky sall
sénégalais au forum pour la paix la
semaine dernière qui a parlé lui de la
représentativité et ça on sait que c'est
un problème majeur la représentativité
au sein du conseil de sécurité
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur les bases de
ce qui existait en 1945
naturellement l'afrique n'est pas
représenté au niveau des membres
permanents l'asie souhaiterait une plus
représenté mais le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui sur les continents ils
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre
et donc là aussi la réforme du conseil
de sécurité bloqué merci dominique
trinquant ancien chef de la mission
militaire française à l'onu d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france rester
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
retournerons devant l'assemblée
nationale où se tient une manifestation
en manifestation de gilet jaune qui ont
rejoint des opposants au projet de loi
sur la sécurité globale et puis nous
évoquerons l'audition de jean castex
devant les députés sur la gestion du coc
vide
venez
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme je monte sur les pentes
appartement on est énervé donnait le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément au loin
de paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui
les dirigent
moi je vois des flacons il passe un tour
de tracts avec du cuivre en campagne il
faut savoir c'est une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles
marc forest td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer si
aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture
et puis les espaces naturels c'est grâce
à la chasse grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse et la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
sont en grande partie conservée grâce à
la gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui
vous avez vingt trois ans vous êtes une
femme qu'est ce que vous espérez
apporter justement à ce monde de la
chasse si je peux aider avec avec ce que
je fais sur les réseaux sociaux etc
skhira a montré un autre aspect de la
chasse et à donner envie à certaines
personnes de la découvrir
ça me fait plaisir
[Musique]
on
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien que difficiles qui avait
une équipe de 25 usines et les retours
pour nous pour nos fournisseurs pour nos
équipes c'était essentiel de rire le
plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
monde d'avant il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver je pensais
que ça allait me rendre plus tolérante
et ben ça m'a rendu plus intolérant
alors par quoi elle s'expose et
justement délirer autour d'un dessert
que j'ai appelé la pêche la patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique le monde dames
[Musique]
le 4 octobre dernier la nouvelle
calédonie à voter sur son avenir avec ou
sans la france et pour la deuxième fois
le nom à l'indépendance a emporté avec
53,26 % alors qu'il était à 56 points 4
au premier plan après le troisième
référendum en 2022 le maintien dans la
france où l'indépendance déboucheront
forcément sur des troubles importants
créé par les perdre au lieu de chercher
des arguments introuvable pour faire
gagner clairement sous le n est elle pas
au dialogue pour concevoir un projet
commun à l'ensemble des signataires des
accords de nous mais que se passera-t-il
quand le retour légales et obligatoires
au suffrage universel montrera que la
majorité est toujours contre
l'indépendance
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que si ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment on peut expliquer que l'un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire à des à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle créait un
incident c'est pour l'éternité
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h heure de paris merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 17 novembre à
manifestations en cours devant
l'assemblée nationale se poursuit est
toujours mais tente d'être dispersés par
les autorités avec notamment les gilet
jaune qui célébrait les deux ans leur
mouvement et qui sont venus rejoindre
les opposants au projet de loi sur la
sécurité examiné par les députés
aujourd'hui un texte qui vise à
sanctionner la diffusion l'image de
policiers comme celles publiées pendant
les manifestations de vie les jo d'impôt
coronavirus de france enregistre plus de
2 millions de cas positifs depuis le
début de l'épidémie annonce tout à
l'heure du directeur général de la santé
gestion de la crise sanitaire avec
l'audition de jean castex est également
aujourd'hui par la commission denquête
de l'assemblée à la veille d'un nouveau
conseil de défense
côté commerçants un objectif est
toujours claire ouvrir le 27 novembre où
les faire mourir alerte les manifs et
les fédérations
la balle est désormais dans le camp du
gouvernement la décision sera prise la
semaine prochaine
sommet annuel des brics aujourd'hui qui
rassemble les grandes puissances
émergentes une réunion virtuelle
organisée sous l'égide de la russie avec
entre autres geignard ball sonar au sin
jean ping ou encore en arène rabaudy les
lumières comptines appelle les brics à
s'unir pour produire son vaccin en masse
les conditions commerciales d'une telle
proposition reste à déterminer
m
les directions tout de suite l'assemblée
nationale en tout cas le quartier de
l'assemblée nationale où l'on retrouve
notre reporter pierre pissavy yvernault
pierre une manifestation qui allie à la
fois les gilet jaune qui célèbre
aujourd'hui les deux ans de leur
mouvement et puis d'entre aux opposants
qui sont venus eux manifester contre la
loi de sécurité globale qui est examiné
à partir d'aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale oui tout à fait stéphanie une
manifestation à la base des gilet jaune
pour célébrer leurs deux ans mais aussi
qu'il était censée retrouver plusieurs
organisations syndicales du côté de
l'assemblée nationale comme vous venez
de le dire pour manifester justement
contre cette loi de sécurité globale
tout s'est très bien passé
cet après midi plusieurs organisations
syndicales étaient présentes notamment
le syndicat national des journalistes ou
à la ligue des droits de l'homme et puis
vers 19h30
la police a voulu dispersé cette petite
place vraiment qui jonchent l'assemblée
nationale et c'est à partir de ce moment
que les choses ont commencé à se
compliquer tous les manifestants ont été
assez justement sur le boulevard saint
germain alors plusieurs cordons de
policiers pour justement barré
rue donc les sorties étaient assez
compliquée elle les policiers qui chacun
de leur côté du de ce boulevard avancé
et puis où finalement fini par nass et
tout le monde le but étant bien sûr de
faire évacuer tout le monde par la
sortie de métro malheureusement les
manifestants n'ont pas entendu de cette
oreille ils étaient nombreux à être
restée voire même assis en pleine route
c'est pour ça que la police a déjà
appelé au pardon usage de gaz
lacrymogène et puis a fait usage
également de sa lance à incendie pour
tenter de disperser les personnes
voilà donc maintenant ça fait plus d'une
heure et demie que la police a tenté de
disperser les ailes et manifestants vous
le disiez tout à l'heure la dispersion
est presque terminée en est toujours en
cours il y encore quelques minutes
il ya même encore des des policiers
derrière moi et puis des manifestants et
qui sont toujours du côté du boulevard
donc une manie une manifestation presque
est dispersée mais pas totalement pierre
pissavy yvernault question nous sommes
en plein confinement est ce que cette
manifestation avait été autorisée -
interdite
alors oui une manifestation qui était
autorisé une manifestation qui était
autorisée jusqu'à 20 heures c'est pour
ça que les forces de l'ordre ont tenté
de disperser une première fois les
manifestants aux alentours de 19h30
une majorité d'entre eux se sont
dispersés dans le calme et puis d'autres
se sont assez justement sur ce boulevard
pour pour voilà continuer continuer la
manifestation beaucoup moins de gilet
jaune
à la fin de cette manifestation on a vu
beaucoup de jeunes souvent des jeunes
aussi alcoolisés et puis c'était une
ambiance un peu particulière à une
ambiance mi revendicative et me festive
puisque on a vu des jeunes avec delà de
la musique voilà des jeunes aussi
parfois défié les forces de l'ordre
donc c'était vraiment une ambiance un
peu particulière qu'on a connus ici ce
soir du côté du quartier de l'assemblée
nationale merci pierre pissavy yvernault
et ses manifestations les deux ans des
gilet jaune mais également la loi de
sécurité globale dont beaucoup de gilet
jaune nous confié se sentir responsable
on en parle tout de suite avec alexis
poulain eric verhaegue fondateur du
courrier des stratèges
bonsoir à tous les deux des xia poulin
et eric verhaegue quand vous voyez ces
manifestations on ignore encore le
nombre de personnes qu'elles ont
rassemblé mais en plein confinement
couvre feu finalement on se dit que ce
mouvement n'est peut-être pas terminée
alexis poulain il ya quand même beaucoup
de colère et notamment autour de cette
loi sur la sécurité globale qui
concentre un petit peu les crispations
quel cadeau pour les deux ans de ce
mouvement des filets jaunes que fait ce
régime de la république en marche
d'offrir une loi qui ferait de la france
le seul pays d'europe à interdire de
filmer finalement les policiers y
compris par les journalistes qui
seraient inquiétés dans l'exercice de
leur métier en violation totale de la
charte de munich ou des lois sur la
liberté de la presse qui sont en vigueur
dans notre démocratie libérale voilà un
résumé parfait de la façon dont le
pouvoir actuel envisage le dialogue et a
peur de la rue au point de réprimer par
la violence y compris les mouvements
lycéens de jeunes lycéens qui occupent
leur lycée pour que des protocoles
sanitaires soient mis en place pour
éviter qu'ils attrapent ce fameux virus
dont on ne les protège pas tant que ça
finalement parce qu'il ne serait pas
mise en danger alors vraiment
voilà où nous en sommes arrivés c'est à
dire que la contestation et il faut
saluer les gens qui sont aujourd'hui
dans la rue pour lutter contre cette loi
de sécurité globale qui est une loi de
surveillance globale qui sont les
veilleurs de notre démocratie avec le
conseil des droits de l'homme de l'onu
beaucoup d'organisations des droits de
l'homme mais également la défenseur des
droits qui a jugé cette loi extrêmement
dangereuses pour nos libertés pour la
liberté de la presse en particulier
donc je crois que seul maintenant les
derniers soutiens à la république en
marche ne voient pas le danger que
représente le gouvernement pour nos
libertés fondamentales de lois
d'exception aux lois d'exception de loi
sanitaire ubuesque en absurdistan
autoritariste voilà à quoi nous en
sommes réduits et heureusement la rue
n'est pas déserter malgré la violence
développer en doctrine par le ministre
de l'intérieur et le gouvernement des
mails mac et que verhaeghe
c'est vrai que voilà hasard ou pas du
calendrier en tout cas les deux ans de
ce mouvement des gilets jaunes coïncide
avec cette loi de sécurité globale qui
est une forme de réponse aussi ces
manifestations qui ont été longuement
filmé et diffusé critiqué est ce qu'on
doit les prendre comme cela moi je veux
dire je suis moins inquiet par cette
disposition de la loi qui je crois est
contenue dans l'article 24 que par
l'article 21 qui de mon point de vue est
encore plus ou beaucoup plus
liberticides puisqu'il prévoit la
possibilité d'équiper les drones de
caméras qui transmettront les données
filmé en temps direct au poste de
commandement
ce qui permettra de faire de la
reconnaissance faciale immédiate des
manifestants
et je pense d'une certaine façon je le
dis avec une présence d'une provocation
amical que cette question du droit de
diffuser les images de policiers
elle est en réalité un peu secondaire
par rapport à la question du droit de
filmer les manifestants et de les
reconnaître en direct individuellement
facialement notamment en faisant
survoler les manifestations par des
drones
et petit à petit on va s'apercevoir que
la surveillance par les drones équipés
de caméras avec des systèmes de
reconnaissance sociale va s'étendre à
l'ensemble du territoire manifestations
ou pas et je crains qu'il y ait de ce
point de vue beaucoup plus de menaces
sur les libertés que ce simple article
24 qui déjà en soi est très inquiétant
je ne conteste absolument pas et je
souscris à ce qu'a dit alexis poulain
sur le sujet merci en tout cas à vous de
eric verhaegue vous restez s'il vous
plaît avec nous puisque on va évoquer à
présent l'audition de jean castex devant
la commission d' enquête sur la gestion
de la crise sanitaire on retrouve tout
de suite
estelle farges qui suit cette audition
pour nos auditions qui est toujours en
cours et celles vous êtes à vous aussi l
assemblée nationale partie plus calme
que peut-on retenir pour le moment de
cette audition du premier ministre
eh bien écoutez à stéphanie comme
olivier ferrand il ya quinze jours et
comme edouard philippe il est environ un
mois jean castex est employé à défendre
l'action de gouvernement pendant plus de
trois heures maintenant puisque vous
l'avez dit
cette audition elle est toujours en
cours le premier ministre qui a récusé
les accusations d'un préparation du
gouvernement en somme il n'y a pas eu
d'erreur d'anticipation a estimé jean
castex et pour étayer son propos le
premier ministre a listé les différents
à décret appuie depuis son arrivée
depuis son entrée en fonction il a aussi
pointé du doigt et bien accueille
parfois peu enthousiaste réservé aux
mesures restrictives mises en place au
cours de l'été et à la rentrée notamment
comme par exemple le porte
la généralisation du port du masque
obligatoire ou la fermeture des bars et
des restaurants à 22 heures ou à minuit
parfois pour certaines villes concernant
à la stratégie du gouvernement sur le
futur à des confinement jean castex a
prévenu il y aura des mesures
restrictives qui persisteront je vous
propose de l'écouter plus vite faire
mieux la phase actuelle de confinement
produira ses effets en termes sanitaires
j'entends plus nous pourrons évoluer et
passer à une phase suivante mais mais la
cheffe de donnez pas votre question qui
ne sera pas le retour à l'entée
confinement c'est à dire que il y aura
des discussions de freinage sont en
cours de calage qui perdureront sur ce
qu'il s'est passé entre le déconfinement
et leur confinement et bien jean castex
l'ani peut-être effectivement que nous
avons à des confiné un peu trop
peut-être aussi que le peuple français a
cru que cette épidémie était être
derrière nous ce sont là les mots 1 du
premier ministre quoi qu'il en soit jean
castex a rappelé que la sécurité à
sanitaire était la priorité du
gouvernement et qu'il ne fallait pas
baisser la garde
même en cas d'annoncé d'amélioration
voilà stéphanie ce que l'on peut retenir
donc de cette audition du premier
ministre qui est donc toujours en cours
merci
sl farge et eric verhaeghe fondateur du
courrier des stratèges et rester avec
nous lis que verhaeghe
on le sent finalement patron de remise
en cause de la part du gouvernement qui
semble finalement avoir totalement
confiance en sa stratégie et et ne pas
effectivement tirer les leçons du passé
oui je pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui une
sorte de grandes incompréhensions entre
le pouvoir au sens large d'ailleurs je
le limiterait pas jean castex et le
reste des français qui se pose de
questions qui restent sans réponse
aujourd'hui la première question
elle est pourquoi at on eu une stratégie
de prévention de dotation en masque de
test des malades aussi restrictive aussi
timoré ou aussi inefficace puisque
encore au début du mois de septembre il
fallait au moins sept ou huit jours dans
le meilleur des cas pour avoir un
résultat au test pcr qu'on faisait de ce
qui permettait à tout le monde de
contaminer en attendant l'arrivée des
résultats toutes les personnes qu'on
pouvait croiser et donc on a bien un
sujet sur l'efficacité de la politique
de prévention et on a un deuxième sujet
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement at il si
peu miser sur la capacité à trouver des
sous le feu à la dame en pourquoi le
gouvernement n'at-il pas pour sur des
molécules comme hiver milk tine comme
l'interféron qui est évidemment bien
connu vous m'entendez on vous un petit
peu perdu eric verhaeghe l'on va vous
laisser achever votre idée en espérant
que cette fois ci ça fonctionne bien
sinon c'est pas malheureusement obligé
de vous vous coupez je vous laisse
terminer à n'ont manifestement veuillez
nous excuser un petit problème de
liaison de réseau avec
notre invité eric verhaegue qu'il
commentait donc cette audition de jean
castex devant la commission de
l'assemblée nationale qui est toujours
d'ailleurs en cours au palais bourbon et
le gouvernement en tout cas devrait se
prononcer la semaine prochaine
concernant les commerçants selon le
porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent leurs rideaux sont baissés depuis
plus de deux semaines maintenant les
fédérations l alerte c'est ouvrir ou
nous faire mourir
peut-être donc dès le 27 novembre en
croire les propos encourageants du
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
hier mais tempérée dans la foulée par
matignon alors ce 27 novembre est ce que
ce sera le cas ce que ça sauvera
peut-être encore la saison ces
commerçants l'ouverture doit-elle être
conditionnée au contexte sanitaire quel
protocole adopté c'est l'objet de notre
face à face
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
enrique casalino chef des urgences à
l'hôpital bichat bonsoir henrique
casalino merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés isabelle ckoi lino président
d'honneur de l'association commerciale
iroise dans les yvelines bonsoir à vous
il est belle c'est quoi dit no mercy
également d'être avec nous donc les
commerçants qui peuvent compter sur en
tout cas le soutien d'une quarantaine de
députés la république en marche qui
contrôlent finalement le gouvernement
demandent une réouverture des
commerçants dès la semaine prochaine ça
vous paraît responsable vous je
m'adresse au docteur henrique casalino
je suppose que c'est pas seulement une
question de responsabilité
c'est une question de responsabilité
individuelle et collective nous - comme
soignants ce que je transmets comme
message c'est que la vie de nos
compatriotes est menacé nous sommes déjà
à plus de 42 mille décès nous avions
fait trente mille 30 et quelques milles
dans la première vague est là avec une
menace d'une vague avec une bague qui
n'a pas réussi
bien heureusement compte tenu des
mesures qui ont été dites et à
s'exprimer avec tout ce qu'elle aurait
pu s'exprimer
nous avons accumulé dix mille ou douze
mille décès supplémentaires ces décès
supplémentaires sont des personnes et
des familles qui ont souffert dans leur
chair et qui sont mortes et à la mort il
n'y a pas de solution
je ne suis pas du tout opposé à l'idée
qu'on puisse commencer progressivement
un process de l'ouverture des vannes et
de revenir à une vie qui ne sera pas
exactement celle d'abord parce que le
virus il va continuer à circuler et nous
devons faire attention et continuer à
porter le masque continuer à garder les
distances antilles mais vous laver les
mains continuer à réduire le nombre de
contacts que nous avons chaque jour et
je suis très sensible à un moment très
difficile que nos amis
j'en passe je vais vous dire dans ma
propre famille mon beau père
restaurateur
je suis très sensible au fait qu'on
puisse imaginer
nd et de voir quelle est la difficulté
la nécessité que les commerçants
puissent rapidement on réouvrir mai mais
tout en disant ça j'essaye d'être
prudents et de faire très attention à ce
que le message ne soit pas on va
réouvrir on va revenir comme c'était
avant ça ce serait vraiment extrêmement
dangereux nous savons qu'il y à un
risque réactivation virale et que nos
capacités hospitalières aujourd'hui sont
très compromise aujourd'hui et encore
plus de 90% de nos lits de réanimation à
l'échelle nationale qui sont occupées
par des collations coville donc notre
hôpital notre système hospitalier ne
pourrait pas faire face à un afflux
supplémentaire et ça on le paiera avec
délaissé pas uniquement des décès liés à
une maladie grave qui de toute façon
auraient pu compromettre notre vie à
nous tuer mais en fait que les gens ne
pourraient pas bénéficier des bonnes
conditions de prise en charge c'est ça
aujourd'hui que nos compatriotes doivent
comprendre il ne fait pas une opposition
en toute logique sanitaire et une
logique économique sommes pas du tout
les deux sont essentiels et pourtant on
a peut-être cette impression de
l'extérieur on va en tout cas entendre
la vie d'isabelle ckoi lino dans le
magasin est fermé depuis le début du
second confinement isabelle séquano
qu'est ce que vous répondez au docteur
quand vous entendez cette argumentation
qui est raisonnée et raisonnable
c'est vrai que la situation est
compliquée ça vous évoque quoi ces
propos écoutez déjà j'étais là précisé
que je chiale dans l'essonne mais pas
dans les yvelines excusez-moi désigne
les exposants je l'écouté et je
comprends son silence désarroi parce que
c'est sûr quant aux soins des personnes
ça paraît évident que tout ce qui est
nobu tycoon pour lui ne touche pas être
je les comprends parce que sa santé est
une chose importante à savoir les gens
se seraient c'est terrible
et qui nous comprennent bien que nous
aussi on souffre énormément et je suis
tout à fait d'accord et et qu'on peut
pas à des comptines et n'importe comment
on sait que les petites des possibilités
elles ont tous des mesures sanitaires
nécessaires
on ne rentre un client qu'à trois
peut-être en somme un casa qu'on peut
faire beaucoup d'efforts pour que ça me
chante pas notamment et ses actes si
j'imagine si on ouvre tous les centres
commerciaux en même temps là oui il y
aura ceux ci mais on peut peut-être se
dire qu'on pouvait juste des commerces à
proximité
et là on ira petit à petit puis si ça
fonctionne bien on ouvrira les autres
pour une fois chacun son tour
vous comprenez nous sommes essentiels
comme tout le monde mais on peut aussi
penser qu'il faut se protéger mais je
suis d'accord avec lui en faisant des
choses on les mesure qu'on peut faire
pour qu'on puisse tous profiter un
maximum et pas recommencer dans quinze
jours la même chose
je pense que tous les commerçants c2a
vent d'espoir si on leur dit qu'on va
ouvrir le 27 août et le 26 au soir
mais non il n'est pas question nous
priva pas le 27 là ce sera terrible au
mystère une régulière parce que avoir un
espoir qui est finie donc demain c'est
la chose la plus terrible des lettres ou
des espoirs
donc prenez le temps de bien réfléchir
hurle dans de bonnes circonstances
et puis le panneau vrai n'importe
comment des grands centres pour une fois
ils peuvent attendre c'est pas gênant
enrique casalino c'est vrai qu'on
comprend parfois le désarroi des petits
commerces quand on voit par exemple
qu'un pays comme l'espagne a fait le
choix inverse a préféré miser voilà sur
les petits commerces qui sont restés
ouverts et ont fermé les grandes
surfaces
pourquoi ne l'at-on pas fait en france
est-ce que ça mais ni vraiment à une
vraie logique médicale
il y a peu de nommer nous savons que il
y un risque de transmission dans
certains endroits
nous avons quelques données sur les
données de transmission dans les 103
clos quelques données sur les
transmissions dans les 103 ouvert il y a
eu un papier très récent qui qui
explique les facteurs de risque que dans
certains environnements notamment la
restauration par exemple parce que c'est
un moment tous les moments de
réalité c'est le moment où on baisse la
garde c'est normal même dans le cercle
familial vous savez qu'aujourd'hui la
plupart des transmissions ont lieu dans
le cercle familial parce que c'est
forcément un endroit dans lequel on
n'est pas masqué ou forcément si on voit
nos enfants on a envie de leur faire une
bise et c'est le moment où on baisse la
garde
il y à une transmission nous le voyons
aussi à l'hôpital on se contaminent
probablement plus dans les moments de
détente lorsqu'on prend un café ont déjà
l'invite les collègues que en
travaillant auprès des patients donc il
faut faire très attention mais moi je
trouve très intéressant avec madame
c'est quoi les i know que finalement en
discutant on arrive à trouver des points
d'entente et que on partage le sens de
la valeur le sens de la protection des
personnes et en même temps de licences
de l'intérêt de la vie économique et le
commerce c'est un élément essentiel de
la vie économique dans notre pays et du
sentiment de bonheur de tous les
compatriotes tout le combat turcs ont
fait un effort considérable pour
respecter le confinement
le couvre-feu initialement et le
confinement suite aujourd'hui donc vont
cueillir les fruits de ce sacrifice
j'en pense que c'est important aussi de
créer des liens de confiance entre nous
touche savoir que moins que l'usagé d'un
commerce que lorsque j'aurai dans un
commerce je me sens en sécurité
et c'est ça qui va faire que j'aurais
continué à y aller vous savez je rentre
d'amérique du sud et jerry hall amérique
du sud après dix mois de confinement les
restaurants les commerces sont ouverts
et en fait ils ont moins de clients que
même les le nombre de places qu'ils
auraient pu recevoir parce que les gens
ont peur les gens ont été tellement
apeuré par lé décès tout le monde
connaît quelqu'un de proche de sa
famille qui est décédé après 10 -
l'épidémie que les gens ont peur et la
peur est beaucoup plus dur que le
confinement
le confinement à me poser par une règle
d'état et a été moins violents que la
peur dans la population d'aller dans des
endroits où elles pouvaient le pas se
sentir en sécurité ne pas se sentir en
sécurité et donc moins le conseil que je
donne un message
j'ai beaucoup d'occupations beaucoup de
mes amis et de ma famille qui sont dans
le commerce
il faut recréer des liens confiance avec
ses clients pour qu'ils sachent que
quand ils vont venir chez vous ils vont
être en sécurité et que tout est fait
pour garantir leur sécurité
en tout cas eu des protocoles sanitaires
chez les commerçants le gouvernement
travaille aussi de son côté un nouveau
protocole sanitaire pour eux comme l'a
confirmé d'ailleurs l1 grise et mini gay
auprès du commerce de l'économie qu'on
écoute l'objectif est d'aboutir à
l'établissement d'un protocole renforcé
commun tous les commerces et la mise à
jour des protocoles spécifiques pour
chaque métier nourrit ignorons avec
bruno le maire olivier ferrand et
l'europe et aux skis vendredi à nouveau
les fédérations de commerce pour valider
ces protocoles et les soumettre au
conseil scientifique
l'objectif étant d'assurer la reprise de
l'activité économique dans les
meilleures conditions sanitaires pour la
période cruciale qui précède les fêtes
de noël et isabelle ckoi dino des
protocoles vous en avais mis en place on
imagine pléthore que vous inspire
justement nouvelles règles encore
écoutez moi je sais pas ce que je
pourrais faire de plus nous avons des du
gène nous avons des masques chaque
client qui retombe bien qui nettoie ses
bas sinon pas à masquer on leur donne on
laisse pas rentrer un seul client dans
la boutique son masque on est on est
vite qui est beaucoup trop de monde à la
fois c'était donc on leur donne des
rendez-vous quand on est fermé comme ça
ils ont la boutique que pour vous on
fait un maximum je ne veux pas ce que je
pourrais faire de plus mais donc à nos
clients lui disent y sentent vraiment en
toute confiance chez nous y'a aucun
souci et tous les collègues font pareil
nous mêmes on n'a aucune envie d'être
malade vous imaginez bien ni et ceux qui
travaillent avec nous donc ça ils
peuvent compter sur nous déjà ce
barrière sont vraiment à poser une à une
entrée dans la boutique une autre sortie
de la boutique nous aurons vraiment
énormément attention et puis on sait
d'ores et déjà que nos clients nous font
confiance ils nous le disent tous les
gens qui comprennent pas pourquoi les
comme tout petit quand même restés
fermés et que les grands eux qui ne
faisait pas attention du tout sans
crever
nous avons été étonnés de voir dans des
grandes surfaces des caddies à la halle
à la caisse les uns contre les autres et
ça ça faisait d'espérer parce que lui
avaient le droit d'être ouvert et nous
qu'on faisait attention on était fermé
après c'est comme tout c'est sûr que
monsieur disait tout à l'heure on sait
même que déjà rien que la peur pour
certains deviendront même par nos
commerces même si on est ouvert donc il
faut qu'ils aient confiance
donc si on en montre qu'on est dans ce
qu'on porte n'importe comment
ils ne viendront pas cotisé euros de
moins importe qu'il ait reconnu nombreux
et bien je fais demi tour
donc les compositions nous fera tout ce
qu'il faut pour qu'il soit en sécurité
chez lui merci en tout cas tous les deux
aînés hickey casalino chef des urgences
à l'hôpital bichat paris isabelle ckoi
lino présidente d'honneur de
l'association commerciale lierroise dans
l'essonne et non pas les yvelines merci
à tous les deux donc quelques instants
rester avec nous nous parlerons de la
hongrie de la pologne qui bloque le plan
de relance européen en utilisant leur
droit de veto à quelques mètres de la
ligne d'arrivée puis nous parlerons du
sommet annuel des brics aujourd'hui elle
me recouche chine appelle les pays à
s'unir pour produire ce vaccin en masse
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme je monte sur les pentes
appartement on est énervé dans l
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément au loin
de paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui
les dirigent mois joseph mâcon il passe
un tour de tracts avec du cuivre en
campagne il faut savoir c'est une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
comment on peut expliquer que l'un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire à des à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion de
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle créait un
incident c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chacun
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois 21h30 heure de paris merci de
nous rejoindre en direct sur rt france
c'est un coup d'arrêt au plan de relance
de l'union européenne de 750 milliards
d'euros approuvé par les 27 membres en
juillet dernier la hongrie et la pologne
ont mis leur véto bloquant le budget de
l'ue eux et provoquant une nouvelle
crise en pleine deuxième vague de la
pandémie de kobe 19
les détails avec leila sarah fain
budapest et varsovie ont opposé leur
véto ce lundi à la validation du budget
de l'union européenne et donc au plan de
relance de 750 milliards d'euros
approuvé par les 27 en juillet ce veto
de la pologne et de la hongrie ouvre une
crise au sein de l'union
alors que les états membres traversent
la deuxième vague de la pandémie de kovy
de 19
le ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères s'est dit ce mardi convaincu
qu'une solution serait rapidement trouvé
pour débloquer le budget de l'union
européenne et le plan de relance massif
malgré le véto hongrois et polonais dans
les heures et les jours à venir nous
allons nous asseoir avec toutes les
parties concernées pour trouver une
solution
l'allemagne qui assure jusqu'à la fin de
l'année la présidence du conseil de
l'union européenne souhaite un règlement
rapide de la situation
mais la hongrie la pologne campent sur
leur position et sont opposés à la mise
en place d'un mécanisme permettant de
priver de fonds européens les pays
accusé de viol et l'état de droit
la hongrie a mis son veto au budget
comme le premier ministre viktor orban
avait prévenu qu'à nous ne pouvons pas
soutenir le projet dans sa forme
actuelle liant le critère de l'état de
droit aux décisions budgétaires c'est
contraire aux conclusions du sommet de
juillet après l'échec de ce lundi les
tractations vont se poursuivre lors
d'une réunion des ministres des affaires
européennes ce mardi deux jours avant un
sommet officiellement consacré à la
lutte contre la pandémie et pour en
parler nous sommes avec philippe muray
ray
kohno ministe bonsoir philippe murray
remercie d'être avec nous l'an gris et
la pologne qui empêche l'europe de
tourner en rond c'est plus que des
réserves c'est un veto oui c'est un veto
tout à fait du plan de relance de
l'union européenne donc qui est pour
l'instant bloquée on se rappelle qu'il a
été proposé en mai négocié en juin
juillet et en fait on se retrouve six
mois après avec pas de plan de relance
alors que l'union européenne a dit c'est
nous qui relance on est donc les états
ne relance pas vraiment donc c'est un
trait problème le budget européen aussi
bloqué pour les sept années à venir pour
l'instant et donc on a bien compris le
sujet c'est que la pologne et de la
hongrie ne veulent pas être mise au pas
par l'union européenne en fait qui
propose de pouvoir couper les aides
d'état si jamais la pologne et la
hongrie n'applique pas toutes les bonnes
politiques comme on veut parce que ça
veut dire quoi l'état de droit en fait
c'est l'état de droit européen
est ce que veulent les polonais les
angoisses et respecter leur état de
droit a eu et respecter la souveraineté
populaire qui a réélu le gouvernement
polonais qui a reconduit déjà deux fois
monsieur roban effectivement il ya deux
sujets immigration pour la pologne et la
hongrie où l'union européenne veut
imposer son agenda devra poser de
l'immigration et les pays ne veulent pas
et les médias et l'état et les médias et
la justice où l'organisation ne convient
pas à l'union européenne
on voit que l'union européenne il ya un
problème démocratique parce qu'elle est
en train de violer la souveraineté
populaire de ces deux pays selon -
concernant l'immigration c'est une chose
concernant le plan de relance après
cette crise est ce que finalement la
hongrie et la pologne ne devrait pas
jouer le jeu de la solidarité comme le
font les autres pays
si mais le problème c'est qu'on veut
leur imposer de l'immigration et qu'ils
ne veulent pas et donc cela seul d'armes
qu'ils ont pour ne pas être mis au pas
être façon plus ou moins définitive
puisque dans ce cas là l'union
européenne pourra leur couper les
subsides qu'ils ont la seule façon
qu'ils ont trouvée c'est cela c'est que
l'union européenne revienne en arrière
sur lier l'état de droit européen entre
guillemets avec avec les plans dead à
ces deux pays quoi mais en fait on voit
que l'union européenne est un petit peu
échoué bloquer le plan avec le breakbeat
n'avance pas ça fait le divorce et il
faudrait que ça avance vite parce que
les pêcheurs français c'est inquiétant
pour eux et pour nos exportations vers
l'angleterre le budget bloquer le plan
de relance est bloqué ce qui pose des
vrais problèmes d'ailleurs puisque la
france l'italie l'espagne pour avoir des
ddd récession de plus de 10% qui
aiderait les états unis ont que 2%
puissions cdz très rapidement et puis ce
dossier de l'immigration qui est bloquée
de flux d'immigration qui est bloqué
depuis six ans où personne n'est
d'accord sur le sujet problème de
l'union européenne c'est qu'elle veut
que tout le monde est exactement le même
modèle
alors que les pays ont des intérêts et
des visions différentes aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il ya un risque d'arriver un
point de non-retour vous les avez évoqué
ces sujets de division il est compliqué
de se mettre d'accord à 27
comment justement vous voyez l'avenir de
l'union européenne dans ces conditions
on voit plutôt une union européenne qui
est sclérosé comme un bloqués comme un
bateau un peu échoué sur la plage qui
arrivent pas avancer et ça vient alors
je pense qu'il y aura un accord quand
même c'est à dire que l'union européenne
va sans doute essayer de retirer ce que
donc ce lien entre ce qu'elle appelle
l'état de droit européen ou de
l'amoindrir fortement et les aide à la
hongrie à la pologne à tous les pays
je pense que la hongrie la pologne nous
représente bien parce que sinon la
france serait une mise au pas aussi par
l'union européenne qui pourrait à lui
capté de l'argent par notre budget de
contribution à l'union européenne et ne
pas nous en remet par les aides si on
fait cela plaise pas le problème c'est
que la méthode de l'union européenne le
traité de l'union européenne qui a été
votée par les parlementaires français en
2000 à 8 avec sarkozy qui avait été
refusé par référendum c'est une union
toujours plus étroite avec toujours plus
de pouvoirs pour l'union européenne et
donc ça devient au bout d'un moment
inacceptable c'est là où c'est en train
de complètement bloquée je pense et
qu'elle porte de sortie trouver
aujourd'hui une porte de sortie
honorable pour l'union dans quel sens
soit elles seraient fermés si elle le
doit
si elle le doit bien ça je pense que ça
serait de rendre de ne pas faire ces
lois au métro palais pays comme elle le
faire et ne pas faire grosso modo
arrêter d'être dans une union de plus en
plus étroites comme elle est le problème
c'est que c'est le traité de l'union
européenne qui est comme ça et qui
bloque tout et puis c'est les logiques
des fonctionnement des institutions
européennes qui est de prendre toujours
plus de pouvoir de récupérer toujours
plus de pouvoir sur les états il
faudrait au contraire que l'union
européenne rende des pouvoirs aux états
pour que les états puissent s'organiser
eux-mêmes selon leur propre intérêt et
je pense que tout le monde y gagnerait
merci beaucoup philippa merrer économise
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france
et aujourd'hui a eu lieu le sommet
annuel des brics qui rassemble les
grandes puissances émergentes une
réunion virtuelle organisée sous l'égide
de la russie avec entre autres jr molson
à roxy jam pin ou encore nine rameau dit
retour sur les créations de ce groupe et
des enjeux de cette session 2020 avec
thé au combat c'est en 2001 que le terme
bric apparaît pour la première fois il
est créée par jim o'neill économiste à
la banque d'investissement goldman sachs
cet acronyme rassemble donc les
principales puissances émergentes qui
doivent connaître une croissance
exponentielle en ce début de siècle
une affirmation qui s'est vérifié durant
la première décennie mais qui est
aujourd'hui remise en cause du fait de
la situation hétérogène de ses membres
si les brics représentait à peine 10 %
du pib mondial en 1990 ils en
représentent désormais plus d'un quart
aujourd'hui
par ailleurs les cinq pays pèse pour
près de la moitié de la population
mondiale ces cinq nations par leur
puissance économique militaire et
démographique offre par ailleurs en
contrepoids aux membres du g7 dont font
partie les états unis l'allemagne la
france ou encore le japon élément
important le pib total des brics
pourraient être supérieur à celui du g7
en 2050
le premier sommet organisé entre le
brésil la russie l'inde et la chine a
lieu en 2009 à yekaterinburg une
conférence qui se tient tous les ans
depuis l'afrique du sud a rejoint le
groupe en 2011
ce 12e sommet est présidé par la russie
et devraient aborder les questions liées
au kobus 19 la lutte contre le
terrorisme le commerce la santé ou
encore l'énergie
une réunion qui s'effectuera de manière
virtuelle en raison de l'épidémie de
couronnes un virus enfin on sait déjà
qui organisera le sommet l'an prochain
il s'agit de l'inde un sommet virtuel à
des brics président et donc par la
russie la correspondance à moscou
d'antoine clairon dans son discours
d'ouverture de ce sommet des brics
vladimir poutine a évoqué la nécessité
d'unir tous les efforts afin de lutter
efficacement contre cette pandémie avec
des conséquences très concrètes la
création prochaine d'un centre de
recherche sur les vaccins commun aux
cinq pays membres à la suite d'une
décision prise il ya maintenant deux ans
en afrique du sud mais aussi la
production possible du vaccin russe
spoutnik v par la chine et parle un
cachet bien sûr la tâche qui consiste à
développer des mesures collectives au
sein des brics pour lutter contre
l'infection renforcer la coopération
entre les services épidémiologiques et
protéger la vie et la santé de nos
citoyens est aujourd'hui au premier plan
je voudrais noter que le fonds russe
d'investissements directs a conclu des
accords avec ses partenaires indiens et
brésiliens sur des essais cliniques du
vaccin spoutnik v ainsi qu'avec des
sociétés pharmaceutiques en chine et en
inde sur l'ouverture de centres de
production de notre vaccin dans ces pays
et pas seulement pour leurs propres
besoins mais aussi pour des pays tiers
je pense que c'est très important des
vaccins russe existe il fonctionne
ils fonctionnent efficacement et ne
présentent pas de danger l'objectif
c'est de lancer une production de masse
suite masseret président étant toujours
dans le cadre de la lutte contre la
copie 19
le président russe a réitéré sa
proposition faite lors de la dernière
assemblée générale des nations unies qui
est de lever au moins temporairement les
sanctions et autres restrictions
commerciales actuellement en vigueur
l'objectif que les populations des pays
en question déjà fragilisée par ces
sanctions puissent accéder
facilement aux produits alimentaires
médicaments et matériel médical
dans son discours il a également été
question des mesures de relance
économique à prendre sitôt passée cette
crise sanitaire en particulier grâce à
la banque de développement communaux
cinq pays membres et forte d'un capital
de 100 milliards de dollars
on l'aura donc compris l'intervention
d'ouverture de vladimir poutine a donc
été très largement marquée par le
contexte sanitaire international pour ce
sommet des brics qui se déroule pour la
première fois entièrement en
visioconférence mais ce sommet on en
parle avec pierre laurin journaliste
spécialiste de la russie bonsoir pierre
laurin merci d'être avec nous si on
comprend bien il n'y aura un vaccin
du côté des pays occidentaux ou
plusieurs et d'autres vaccins on va dire
les procédés techniques d'ailleurs
différente du côté des brics oui
effectivement les vaccins russes ne sont
pas les vaccins de la toute dernière
génération qui sont en train d'être
mises au point en occident mais il
repose sur des techniques un peu plus
ancienne et donc qu'ils sont
certainement plus fiable du point de vue
de l'utilisation directe par les
populations
il n'ya pas vraisemblablement d'effets
délétères qui peuvent se produire à long
terme les effets secondaires
on les connaît ils sont relativement
minimes et donc ce que les russes
veulent faire avec leurs vaccins
spoutnik v et deux autres qui sont en
cours de préparation
c'est de lancer une production massive
en collaborant avec leurs partenaires
des brics
alors effectivement un appel
aux brics soit 40% de la population
mondiale à s'unir pour produire des
vaccins en mal selon vous est-ce que ça
a pas aboutir
de toute manière ça va aboutir dans la
mesure où actuellement la seule chose
qui peut rassurer les populations
mondiales c'est un vaccin
quelle que soit l'importance de la
pandémie quelle que soit l'évolution des
épidémies dans différents pays au cours
des prochains mois il apparaît
aujourd'hui clairement que personne ne
sera totalement rassuré avant qu'il y
ait une diffusion importante massive des
vaccins l'avantagé également des des
vaccins russe c'est que ce ne sont pas
des vaccins qui dépendent de grands
groupes cotés en bourse
c'est à dire que les effet d'annonce
boursiers n'existe pas donc il y a un
travail qui se fait naturellement
s'il y a des effets d'annoncé il ya eu
un effet d'annoncé
cet été avec l'annnonce du scouting et
c'est plutôt du point de vue politique
que cela se situe mais il n'y a pas de
conflit d'intérêts financiers entre ceux
qui fabriquent ce qui met au point le
vaccin et ceux qui le diffuse et
pourtant pierre laurin on peut le dire
voilà sans se tromper que cette annonce
cet été a été accueillie avec un certain
scepticisme voire ricanements dans les
pays
parmi les pays occidentaux idem
d'ailleurs pour donald trump qui avait
promis un vaccin avant novembre
finalement deux jours après sa défaite
non officiel pour l'instant aux
élections fire et biotech annonce est
effectivement l'efficacité d'un autre
vaccin suivi de près par par moderna
comment vous expliquez ça c'est deux
poids deux mesures finalement je ne
chante pas là pour le coup autant il ya
beaucoup de deux poids deux mesures dans
tout ce que l'on entend dans les
déclarations occidentales
autant là ce n'est pas réellement cela
autant c'est là c'est une méfiance à
l'égard de ceux qui peuvent venir de
russie ce qui est complètement absurde
parce que autant on vous affirme que la
science russe est formidable pour mettre
au point des virus pathogènes des agents
neurotoxiques toxiques etc
et là on dit ah mais ils ont une avance
considérable sur les autres pays
mais en ce qui concerne les vaccins ce
qui est exactement les mêmes procédures
médicales et techniques
alors là on vous dit un homme et ils
sont pas à la hauteur en tout cas ce que
l'on voit aujourd'hui c'est que healy a
d'un côté un vaccin qui semble commencer
à fonctionner à être produit qu'est ce
que cela va donner à l'avenir il faut
rester prudent et le l'autre côté nous
avons beaucoup d fed annonce une
surenchère c'est efficace à 90 à 92 à 94
8% et à chaque fois c'est au bout de
quelques jours ou de quelques semaines
remis en cause parce que eh bien il ya
un problème il ya quelqu'un qui est mort
peut-être pas de cela mais on ne sait
pas donc il faut arrêter il faut
ralentir et c'est de l'autre côté les
les rues sont très ouverts sur ce qui
concerne la mise au point de leurs
vaccins il donne accès à tout ce qu'il
faut il n'y a pas deux
zones d'ombré elle est là en soit on
voit que progressivement ça marche et ça
fonctionne
et bien entendu il faut rester prudent
on ne sait pas quelles seront réellement
les délais de diffusion de ce vaccin où
il sera produit
est-ce que son efficacité sera aussi
forte que les autorités le prétendent
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup d'inconnu
mais en tout cas ce que l'on voit c'est
que d'un côté on essaye de progresser
d'une manière à peu près logique et de
l'autre côté on apprend des grandes
avancées qui se traduise immédiatement
par une montée des actions suivie d'une
vente par les dirigeants de ces
entreprises qui en gagnent en engrangent
des bénéfices et un terme est bien au
chaud on apprend que c'est pas
exactement où si on est aussi clair
qu'on l'annoncé quelques jours
auparavant
merci beaucoup pierre laurin d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france
et dans le reste de l'actualité jeu
d'alliances dans le pacifique le premier
ministre japonais a reçu son homologue
australien en jeu la signature d'un
accord de défense historique entre tokyo
et canberra un rapprochement au coeur de
la mise en oeuvre d'une stratégie plus
globale pour contrer la chine et l'inde
masculine inde japon australie etats
unis alors que la chine inquiète les
grandes puissances ali pour faire face
au géant asiatique
à l'origine une alliance née en 2007 et
portant le nom de quadrilatères al
security dialogue ou quad dont le but
est de promouvoir un dialogue
stratégique entre ces quatre pays
membres un partenariat informel qui
entend contrer l'expansion chinoise dans
la région
car entre ses revendications
territoriales en mer de chine
méridionale et le développement des
nouvelles routes de la soie pékin et ses
ambitions incite ces quatre nations à
faire bloc
début octobre les quatre ministres des
affaires étrangères se sont rencontrés à
tokyo en pleine pandémie avec un
objectif plus ou moins explicite en tant
que partenaire de ce quad il est plus
que jamais essentiel que nous
collaborions pour protéger nos peuples
et nos partenaires contre l'exploitation
la corruption et la coercition du parti
communiste chinois récemment l'ordre
international a été remis en question
dans divers domaines et le nouveau
coronavirus accentuer cette tendance
nous croyons une région régi par des
règles non par le pouvoir
nous croyons à l'importance fondamentale
des droits individuels et à une région
où les conflits
résolu conformément au droit
international le mantra du quad élaborer
une stratégie pour un indo pacifique
libre et ouvert la région est une zone
de transit névralgique pour le commerce
mondial
riche en ressources naturelles où se
situent les intérêts de nombreux acteurs
internationaux washington désire
conserver une liberté de navigation
absolue dans la zone tokyo cherche à
s'affirmer comme puissance régionale de
référence et appelle à bâtir une asie
élargie avec l'inde et le japon pour
référent la chine elle s'impose de plus
en plus comme le leader de la zone
ce dimanche porté par pékin un
partenariat économique global incluant
15 pays d'asie et du pacifique a été
conclu si le japon et l'australie en
font bien partie
les luttes d'influencé s'intensifier
dans la région et une proximité accrue
entre canberra et tokyo accenture est un
peu plus cette polarisation à l'oeuvre
dans le pacifique
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouve dans quelques minutes pour 1
point complet sur l'actualité
22h15 exactement
[Musique]